[Music]
among the pantheon of corporations that
have emerged out of silicon valley
uber occupies a special place the
company is worth a hundred billion
dollars
hundreds of billions of dollars worth of
trips and delivery orders have been
booked using its app
it gets tens of billions of dollars in
revenue each year
uber is everywhere and the narrative of
uber is also everywhere
it says that uber is innovative that it
can disrupt the taxi industry and make
money
doing it and it can offer flexibility
and opportunity to its army of drivers
everybody wins there's one problem
none of that is true let's start with
one basic fact
for a company so prominent there's
something very strange
uber has never not once turned a single
profit
you might be confused how can it be that
such a large company
with such a popular service has simply
never made
money when you find out the answer you
discover something important
you discover that uber is fundamentally
a scam a company that exists to scam as
investors
its users and most importantly to scam
its workers
despite everything you might hear uber's
not a technology company
while the company may brag about its
sophisticated algorithm
in reality uber is just another taxi
company there's nothing fundamentally
more efficient about uber than there was
with your local taxi service
the business is the same there's no real
way to innovate someone driving someone
or something from point a
to point b using an app to match riders
with drivers is so simple that
local taxi companies do the same thing
in fact
uber is less efficient than taxi
companies most normal taxi companies
don't spend huge amounts on marketing or
lobbying or corporate headquarters
they don't pay their ceo 45 million
dollars a year
uber has higher costs than traditional
taxi operators in
every category except fuel so why is
uber everywhere while taxi companies go
out of business
it all goes back to uber's master plan
first with massive amounts of money from
venture capitalists
uber subsidized significantly cheaper
rides than what taxi companies could
offer
to attract customers away from them then
after years of undercutting competitors
and driving them to bankruptcy resulting
in a wave of suicides by cab drivers
uber established near monopolies in
local markets now
uber is often the default way to get
around if you don't have a car
and once uber has eradicated its
competition it can make itself
profitable
at expense of users and drivers raising
its fares to what taxis offered
were higher while pushing down drivers
wages
the plan is not efficiency it's monopoly
and that's not just me theorizing a
73-page
article in the transportation law
journal took a deep look at uber's
business and concluded one thing
uber has no ability now or in the
foreseeable future
to earn sustainable profits in a
competitive marketplace
uber's investors cannot earn returns on
the money they invest
without achieving levels of market
dominance that would allow them to
exploit anti-competitive market power
so that is uber's grand plan it is not
increasing the productivity or
efficiency of the industry that it's in
it's subsidizing its rides with venture
capital cash until it can build a
monopoly and do whatever it wants
so users who buy uber's narrative may be
getting scammed
but no one is getting it worse than
uber's workers
so uber relies on classifying drivers as
independent contractors
in the united states that means an
individual provides services
to a company but is independent of the
company and its control
uber says that because drivers can
choose what work to accept and for how
long
they're fully independent now most of
uber's workers drive part-time
but they actually do relatively little
driving and 90
of them quit each year the majority of
uber's labor is done by a smaller group
of workers who drive
full-time for the company so who are
these drivers in cities like new york
the vast majority are immigrants from
places like india
bangladesh and haiti they desperately
need cash to support their families and
send remittances back home
these are people at the very margins of
our society and how does uber treat them
uber treats them like a pool of cheap
labor easy to exploit
and then discard uber's always been
clear about one thing
it does not care about its drivers at
uber's green light centers
where drivers register with the company
they were not even allowed to enter
bathrooms reserved for employees
in fact when uber was talking about how
it would become profitable
it stated clearly that it wanted to get
rid of its drivers and transition
entirely to self-driving cars but uber's
technology was so bad that after burning
billions of dollars it had to give up
so for now uber is stuck with its
drivers and in order to appear like it's
coming closer to profitability
it's been cutting their wages since
2015. whenever uber increases its cut
from each trip or reduces the minimum
rate for drivers
its margins improve by that much
immediately as a result
uber drivers regularly earn less than
the minimum wage
after taking hidden costs like fuel into
account
the average uber driver earns a little
over nine dollars an hour
about 50 less than what taxi drivers
made before uber
in fact half of uber drivers live at or
below
the poverty level 20 of them have to use
food stamps to survive
unable to afford a home some drivers
even sleep in their cars
drivers with nothing to their name get
trapped in predatory car rental schemes
promoted by uber they garnish your wages
until you've paid it off with interest
one study from georgetown found that a
third of drivers reported falling into a
debt trap
some ended up earning less than five
dollars an hour
and because its drivers are technically
independent contractors
uber can avoid pesky requirements like
minimum wages
health insurance or paid sick leave
drivers can't unionize to bargain for
better conditions
uber has all the power and it makes sure
it can stay that way
when california tried to classify
drivers as employees
uber spent hundreds of millions of
dollars on a campaign to overturn it
with a ballot proposition
ridden by uber's lawyers and even though
uber talks about flexibility
that's not what drivers actually
experience drivers may not have
physical bosses to order them around but
they're ruled by something
even worse an algorithmic overseer
that's more intrusive
than any flesh and blood boss could ever
be uber's only actual innovations
are in surveilling and disciplining its
workforce
they're always watching monitoring
driving behavior
calculating fraud profiles using
invisible secret functions
to discipline drivers as well as
customers fall below an arbitrary
threshold for ratings
fired reject too many trips because you
don't want to lose any money
fired did a customer make a false report
fired
so that's the freedom that uber offers
it frees drivers
to make below minimum wage to sleep in
their cars to beg
for five-star ratings and work
themselves to the bone but at the end of
the day
uber like other gig companies is an
innovator
not in technology but in exploitation
it's leading the war against labor in
ways other companies
never thought possible it oversees a
pool of atomized
ultra exploited laborers writes its own
regulations
and has done it all without earning a
single cent of profit
imagine what sort of world they'll need
to start making one
i'm edward ungueso jr staff writer
advice for the grovel institute
[Music]
[Music]
you